michael saylor was on cnbc recently and
they asked him what is going on with
bitcoin and if he's wrong he's gonna
lose a lot of money michael had a great
point and that he said well there's only
two things that you could think as the
anti-argument against bitcoin you could
either believe that it's not real or you
could believe that it's actually gonna
get banned by the u.s government and
naturally he broke down that argument
and he stated that both of those sides
of the argument they're wrong if
bitcoin's not going to zero it's going a
million here's exactly what michael had
to say on cnbc
you've made a significant bet on bitcoin
so if all of this maturity occurs and if
you see all of this
flush cash getting wiped out of the
system this in a sense leveraged money
could that then be that you see bitcoin
coming down considerably and then you
stand to lose quite significantly we
don't see it that way we actually see it
the opposite which is uh the big
question forever has been uh is this
real and and if it's real is it going to
be banned the deniers said this wasn't
real and of course they're being
discredited as the administration and
congress and regulators embrace bitcoin
and the skeptics have always said well
it's real it's better than gold but it's
so good it's too good to be true and the
government's got to ban it so if the
deniers are wrong and if the skeptics
are wrong and it's pretty obvious
they're both wrong at this point it's
not going to zero and if it's not going
to zero it's going to a million because
it's obviously better than gold at
everything that gold wants to be and and
if it was just worth what goals worth
it'd be 500 000 a coin so i i really
think we've crossed the chasm there with
uh with the bill that was put on on the
capitol floor today by two senators a
democrat and republican
and uh and with janet yellen's speech at
american university april 7th where she
recited the legend of satoshi nakamoto
and explained why digital assets are
critical to the future of the united
states people are realizing that this is
a real thing it's going to be with us
and bitcoin is like it or not it's
unique there really is no network in the
world that has its its level of adoption
or its level of security and if i put
500 billion dollars on the table and
gave it to you and said create another
one you couldn't create another bitcoin
for 500 billion dollars right now so
i i'm i'm very bullish about where we're
headed from here now that's a great
articulation of what exactly michael's
views are and of course he's not just
talking he's taking billions and
billions of dollars he's invested it
into bitcoin sits on his personal
balance sheet and also at his public
company if bitcoin's not going to zero
it's going to a million but not because
that's just some price hoppium but
because instead it's the hardest sound
as money the world's ever seen and
naturally it does everything that gold
does just better and so seeing somebody
like michael saylor go on national
television talk to wall street public
companies and the average investor and
explain exactly why both the skeptics
and the haters are wrong it's exactly
what bitcoin was built to do hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time